"THE FIVE" ."
FOX NEWS ALERT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP NOW SAYING HE
WON'T SIGN A STOPGAP SPENDING
BILL WITHOUT THE CASH FOR THE
WALL.
WE WILL GET TO THAT BUT FOR
SOMETHING MORE IMPORTANT.
ONCE AGAIN, DONALD TRUMP
ATTACKED THE MEDIA, ACCUSING
THEM OF FAKE NEWS.
WAIT, I WAS HALF WRONG.
FAKE NEWS, YES.
BUT IT WASN'T TRUMP.
IT WAS INCOMING CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ WHO
BASHED POLITICO FOR "GOSSIP THAT
MASQUERADES AS REPORTING."
OF ONE PIECE, SHE SAYS THIS
STORY HAS NOT A SINGLE NAME OR
VERIFIABLE SOURCE.
MY DAD HAD A NAME FOR JUNK
ARTICLES LIKE THIS.
BIRDCAGE LINING.
IT'S MORE AWKWARD THAN FAKE NEWS
BUT IT WORKS.
I AM AWAITING THE MEDIA
OUTREACH.
HOW DARE SHE ATTACKED THE PRESS.
ISN'T SHE AWARE THAT SHE'S
PUTTING REPORTERS IN HARM'S WAY?
I KID.
OF COURSE THE PRESS WILL SAVE
ALL THAT FOR TRUMP AND NEVER
SHOOT INSIDE THE TENT.
AOC IS A SOCIALIST, PUTTING HER
SMACK DAB IN THE MIDDLE OF THEIR
OWN YURT.
I USE THE WORD YURT.
GOOD FOR HER.
SEE, TRUMP'S CHIEF IMPACT IS
GIVING VOICE TO THE TICKED OFF
MASSES WHO FOR SO LONG HAVE PUT
UP WITH HALF-TRUTHS PASSED OFF
AS WHOLE TRUTHS.
TRUMP IS YOU AND ME YELLING AT
THE TV BACK WHEN THERE WAS SUCH
A THING AS TV.
BASHING FAKE NEWS IS NOW
SPREADING TO PEOPLE LIKE AOC.
WHO SHOULD SPEAK UP.
IF SHE DOESN'T, IF YOU DON'T,
WHAT HAPPENS?
THEN REPORTERS CAN DECIDE WHAT
THEY WANT TO WRITE FIRST AND
THEN FIND THE SOURCES TO SHAPE A
PIECE TO THEIR LIKING.
GERMANY'S MOST INFLUENTIAL
NEWSMAGAZINE HAD ITS STAR
REPORTER JUST CONFESSED TO
MAKING UP STORIES FOR SEVEN
YEARS.
GET THIS.
HE WAS CNN'S JOURNALIST OF THE
YEAR IN 2014.
WE ARE LIVING IN A SIMULATION.
I WELCOME AOC FOR JOINING TRUMP
IN FIGHTING FAKE NEWS.
PRETTY SOON SHE WILL BE EATING
WELL DONE STEAK WITH KETCHUP.
DANA.
>> Dana: ISSUE BEGIN?
>> Greg: KNOW SHE EATS SALMON.
>> Dana: HAVE YOU BEEN
WATCHING THE VIDEOS?
>> Greg: I THINK SHE HAS
POTENTIAL FOR BEING UNORIGINAL
PERSON.
EVEN THOUGH SHE'S A SOCIALIST.
I THINK SHE IS VERY AND IN THE
SENSE THAT LITERALLY SHE ENGAGES
EVERYTHING.
SHE HAS AN ANSWER.
SHE WILL TALK TO PEOPLE.
SHE WILL SAY STUPID STUFF BUT
SHE OWNS IT.
>> Dana: IN THIS CASE WITH THE
REPORTERS, IN MY SPIRITS, IT'S
VERY RARE THAT THERE IS NO TRUTH
TO A STORY.
I'M SURE SHE'S GOT A LOT OF
PEOPLE AROUND HER.
I'M SURE THERE IS PEOPLE
SPEAKING ON HER BEHALF.
MAYBE THEY WERE TALKING IN THE
HALLWAY AND HE GETS TO POLITICO
AND THEY READ ABOUT IT.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
SHE HAS TO LOCK THAT DOWN, AND
THAT SHE DOESN'T CARE.
SHE MIGHT NOT.
>> Greg: I THINK EVERYBODY
CARES.
HERE'S MY THEORY, JASON.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
YOU LOOK GREAT FOR A
GRANDFATHER.
HE IS A GRANDFATHER.
YOU LOOK YOUNGER THAN ME.
>> Juan: IMAGINE HOW I FEEL
ABOUT THAT.
>> Greg: YOU LOOK GREAT AS A
GRANDFATHER TOO.
YOU LOOK TERRIBLE AS A
GRANDFATHER, LISA.
WHERE MY GOING?
HERE'S MY POINT.
PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE HOW BIASED
THE MEDIA IS UNTIL THEY WRITE
ABOUT THEM, SO WHEN YOU GET AN
ARTICLE WRITTEN ABOUT YOU, YOU
GO "THIS DIDN'T HAPPEN."
TRUMP KNOWS THAT BECAUSE HE'S
BEEN IN THE MEDIA FOREVER.
AOC GETS SOMETHING WRITTEN ABOUT
HER.
IF YOU'VE BEEN THE OBJECT OR
SUBJECT OF A PIECE, YOU KNOW.
>> Juan: WHAT DID HE DO FOR A
LIVING?
>> Jason: I GO TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., AND ARTICLES
IN BIG PUBLICATIONS, THEY NEVER
CALL YOU.
THEY NEVER ASK A QUESTION.
SUDDENLY THEY ARE THE EXPERT.
THEY WRITE ALL THESE THINGS
ABOUT IT.
I LIKE WHAT DONALD TRUMP JR.
WEEDED OUT TO OCASIO-CORTEZ
WHICH SAID IMAGINE WHAT IT'S
LIKE IF THEY ACTUALLY HATE YOU.
THERE IS A LOT OF TRUTH TO THAT.
IT'S ENDLESS HOW MANY THINGS GET
WRITTEN ABOUT SOMEBODY WITH NO
SOURCES.
"THE FIVE" CAN I ASK YOU
SOMETHING?
DO YOU THINK IT'S NOT TRUE THAT
SOMEBODY ON THEIR STAFF SO THAT
THEY WERE GOING TO TRY TO GO
AFTER HAKEEM JEFFRIES.
>> Greg: FAKE NEWS.
I'M DEFENDING HER.
FAKE NEWS.
>> Lisa: WE HAVE SEEN
GENUINELY FAKE NEWS WITH ABC'S
BRIAN ROSS A STORY ABOUT MICHAEL
FLYNN.
CNN'S STORY ABOUT WIKILEAKS.
THERE ARE LEGITIMATELY SOMETIMES
THESE COMPLETELY NO FACTS AT
ALL, COMPLETELY FAKE NEWS WHICH
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS CALLED OUT.
I THINK ONE OF THE BEST THINGS
ABOUT THIS ADMINISTRATION,
PULLING THE CURTAIN BACK IN THE
SENSE THAT THERE'S NEVER BEEN
OBJECTIVITY IN THE MEDIA,
PRACTICALLY WHEN IT PERTAINS TO
REPUBLICANS.
I'M KIND OF GLAD PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS CALLED OUT AND EXPOSED IT.
NOW YOU CAN MAKE THE ARGUMENT
THAT HE'S TAKEN IT TOO FAR.
THAT'S COMPLETELY FAIR.
I'M GLAD HE'S CALLING IT OUT.
ONE OF MY FAVORITE MOMENTS WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP, OWNER OF THE
FIRST INTERVIEWS WHEN HE TOOK
OFFICE.
DAVID ASKED HIM ABOUT THE
WOMEN'S MARCH.
HE WAS LIKE, YOU KNOW, MARCH FOR
LIFE IS COMING UP.
HE NEVER PAID ATTENTION TO IT.
YOU DON'T COVER IT.
HE SHOULD HAVE SEEN HIS FACE.
HE'S NOT USED TO REPUBLICANS
CALLING HIM OUT.
REPORTERS AREN'T USED TO BE
CALLED OUT ON IT.
I APPRECIATE THAT ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
PUTTING THAT OUT ME OPEN IS
HEALTHY AND GOOD FOR THE
COUNTRY.
>> Greg: JUAN, OBVIOUSLY YOU
ARE AN AWARD-WINNING JOURNALIST.
YOU CAN ANSWER THIS BETTER THAN
ANYBODY.
INACCURATE NEWS PROSPERS.
IF IT MATCHES THE ASSUMPTIONS OF
ITS PEERS.
IT COULD BE ON THE RIGHT OR
LEFT.
THE GERMAN WRITER, THE PIECES
HAD PRETTY MUCH MATCHED THE
STORY LINES THEY WANTED.
THEY DIDN'T BOTHER TO QUESTION
IT.
IT'S ABOUT STORIES THAT ARE
ALMOST TOO GOOD TO BE TRUE THAT
PEOPLE GET AWAY WITH.
>> Juan: WHAT I THINK IT'S --
LET ME SAY WE LIVE IN TWO ERRORS
HERE.
THE ARROW WHERE EVERYTHING WAS
IN FRAGMENTED IF YOU GO TO YOUR
MEDIA BUBBLE TO GET YOUR NEWS
AND YOU WANT YOU WANT YOUR
OPINION IS AFFIRMED.
YOUR PRE-EXISTING OPINION
AFFIRMED SO YOU GO TO PLACES
THAT YOU THINK WILL AGREE WITH
YOU.
IN THE PRIOR WORLD, THERE WERE
STORIES.
JANET COOKE.
JASON BLAIR AND PEOPLE LIKE
THAT, THEY MADE UP STORIES.
THEY MADE UP STORIES.
I THINK THIS GUY FITS INTO THAT
MODE, VERY YOUNG, VERY
AMBITIOUS.
FAST RISING STAR.
>> Dana: WILL WHY NOT JUST
WRITE FICTION?
>> Greg: HE WAS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: WRITE A NOVEL OR
WRITE SHORT STORIES.
>> Greg: BECAUSE HE GOTTEN SO
MUCH -- SO ESTEEMED SO QUICKLY,
HE FELT PRESSURE TO KEEP
IMPROVING.
>> Juan: HE'S A LYING DOG.
THE THING ABOUT IS IT THAT IT
BECOMES IN THE MOMENT WHERE
EVERYONE IS IN THE MEDIA BUBBLE,
BECOMES POLITICIZED.
DER >> -- A LOT OF PEOPLE ONT
DER >> -- A LOT OF PEOPLE ONE
RIGHT WERE SALIVATING
WHEN YOU GO TO A LOT OF WEBSITES
TODAY, DEPENDING ON YOUR
POLITICAL ORIENTATION.
YOU HAVE TO STOP AND THINK IS IT
REAL?
IS IT TRUE?
>> Greg: I THINK THAT'S
HEALTHY.
>> Juan: WHAT I WOULD CALL A
GATEKEEPER FUNCTION WE COULD SAY
FOR EXAMPLE JASON WAS
COMPLAINING ABOUT
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
"THE WASHINGTON POST" IS NOT
GOING AWAY TOMORROW.
THEY HAVE TO PROTECT THEIR
BRAND.
WHAT JASON CALLS AND COMPLAINS
OR WRITES A LETTER, THEY DO
RESPOND.
>> Lisa: YOU SEE STORIES LIKE
LIKE --
REMEMBER THE NIKKI HALEY STORY
WITH THE CURTAINS.
NIKKI HALEY SAID HER STAFF TOLD
THEM THIS IS THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY RAN THE STORY ANYWAY.
A LOT OF TIMES YOU HAVE MEDIA
REPORTERS THAT DON'T CARE
PARTICULAR WANTED PAINT FOR SAID
ADMINISTRATION IN A BAD LIGHT OR
REPUBLICANS.
THAT BIAS DOES EXIST.
>> Dana: I THINK THEY ARE
DIFFERENT THINGS.
IT'S DIFFERENT FROM WHAT AOC IS
COMPLAINING ABOUT.
IF SHE'S CONCERNED ABOUT IT, SHE
NEEDS TO GET A HANDLE ON THE
PEOPLE AROUND HER.
SHE HAS TO MAKE SURE SHE HAS
PEOPLE SHE TRUSTS THAT ARE GOING
TO SPEAK ON HER BEHALF.
THE EDITORS OF THE PIECE SAID WE
HAVE THREE SOURCES.
I DON'T THINK THEY ARE ALL
LYING.
>> Greg: I DO.
I'M DEFENDING HER.
>> Dana: I'M NOT NOT DEFENDING
HER.
>> Greg: WHY DO YOU HATE HER?
I DON'T LIKE UNNAMED SOURCES.
I FEEL LIKE WHO COULD IT BE?
>> Dana: LET ME GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE.
THREE MONTHS AGO I GOT A CALL
FROM SOMEBODY, A FRIEND CLOSE TO
SOMEBODY IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
I CHECK IT WITH SOMEBODY ELSE IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THEY SAY YOU CAN TAKE THIS TO
THE BANK.
THIS IS TRUE.
SO I SAY IT.
THE ON THE RECORD SPOKESPERSON
SAYS THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
OKAY, IF YOU THINK THERE'S
PEOPLE IN YOUR BUILDING AREN'T
TELLING A DIFFERENT STORY COMING
WRONG.
FOR HER, FOR HER SUCCESS,
SURROUND YOURSELF WITH PEOPLE